in since last email to al-jazeera
newsroom in qatar
walid al-amari al-jazeera's jerusalem
bureau chief talking about the moments
before israeli forces shot dead his
colleague on the 11th of may in janine
this event brought together the people
who lodged a complaint with the
international criminal court in april on
behalf of four palestinian journalists
killed or maimed by israeli fire while
clearly identifiable as press
now they're adding new names to the file
sharing
one of the arab world's best-known
reporters and her colleague samudi shot
in the back and injured moments before
shireen was hit one message came through
loud and clear at this event there's no
lack of evidence but there's also new
momentum behind calls for international
action over israel's targeting of
journalists
it is a war crime to deliberately target
journalists and it is a war crime to
cover up other war crimes it is to stop
and to silence objective reporting on
the ground the documentation of human
rights abuse that's why journalists are
targeted and that's why we say this case
is so serious and the icc ought to be
looking at the targeting of journalists
in particular as opposed to other
civilian deaths
the case is being brought by the
international federation of journalists
the palestinian journalists syndicate
and the international center of justice
for palestinians they say last year
marked a turning point when the icc
ruled its jurisdiction extended to the
occupied palestinian territory according
to reporters without borders at least 30
journalists mostly palestinians have
been killed by israeli fire in the west
bank and gaza since 2000.
the israeli armies never acknowledged
any responsibility
how hopeful are you that the icc can
down the line achieve any kind of
justice for shireen and other
palestinian journalists
given the fact that israel is not party
to the icc and given its track record of
of non-investigation pre-trial chamber
ruling um is very clear the icc's
jurisdiction criminal jurisdiction
extends over the territories that we're
speaking about
um that means that
the icc prosecutor can issue a warrant
for the arrest of perpetrators and then
that has severe consequences for the
individual perpetrator whether they're
inside israel or not
al jazeera is preparing its own dossier
which it'll submit to the icc as well as
sharing's killing it includes the
israeli airstrike in gaza that destroyed
the offices of al jazeera and the
associated press a year ago
on thursday the palestinian authority
says its own investigation had
established that israeli forces
deliberately shot sharin abu hakla
hitting her in the head while she was
trying to escape
[Music]
[Applause]
the israeli media has reported that the
military has no plans to launch a
criminal investigation nadine baba
al-jazeera london